et elle est je pense à des trucs sexy
légaux sans gluten merde
est ce que j'ai dit ça à voix haute ah
ah désolé eu une seconde
c'est ce que j'ai oublié d'acheter un
peu dans les courses maintenant je fais
du sport
j'ai autre chose à faire
tu est dégoûté de tout ce qui touche au
sexe ça c'est parce que tu es porno
femme essaye de dire quelque chose de
vraiment crade et à toi de décider
c'est moi ou le porno
de créa
je veux ta grosse et nord
[Musique]
attention j'entre je voulais juste
m'assurer que tout allait bien quoi quoi
non j'suis en médiation méditation
méditation mais attends pourquoi t'es
rayonnante
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un alors j'ai
rédigé une liste de choses de qu a fait
le ridicule n'a jamais tué personne
non
au lavage je voudrais savoir un truc
vous faites du pilat tout
waouh ça alors c'est dingue ce que tu as
changé voulez danser
[Musique]
j'espère ne pas être à la hauteur je
crois que tu as peur de te remettre en
selle mais c'est comme le vélo ça
s'oublie pas
[Musique]
c'est comme d'un vaste tués dans patrick
swayze
comme ça je vais savoir tout ce que je
veux surtout était certaine de vouloir
savoir pour l'état raison ça pourrait
mais l'histoire avant même qu'elle ait
commencé comme ça pourrait être le début
d'une histoire qu'il s'arrêtera là m
qu'est ce qui est quand même temps
[Musique]
il faudrait savoir comment fonctionne ce
truc excellent choix
j'en ai mis aujourd'hui commencez à vous
en avez mis lui si je crois que vous
avez mis de la crème pour les érections
se relève
[Musique]